[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم في حلقه جديده من برنامجكم
الندوه الحضارات القديمه في الجزيره
العربيه هل النقاش حولها والحديث عنها ترف
تضيع وقت موضوع يهم شويه حقنا الاثار ولا
اللي يزور متحف ولا اللي ام ان الحضارات
القديمه في الجزيره العربيه طبعا الجزيره
العربيه مساحته الاعظم ثمثلها اليوم
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لا هذا حديث مهم
وحديث ينصب في صميم الرؤيه وفي صميم البحث
عن مقومات للهويه السعوديه مرتكزات اعماق
الهويه السعوديه هذا فيما يخص الجانب
السياسي والتنظير الثقافي عن هويتنا من
نحن وفي جانب اخر لها مردود اقتصادي لان
هي مورد من اعظم الموارد السياحيه في
العالم الاثار وزياره الاثار ولنا مثل
بالاهرامات وباثينا وما الى ذلك كما انها
من اهم
المنابع التي تغذي العلوم علوم
وغيرها من العلوم بل حتى علوم مثلا تاريخ
الحيوانات مثل الحديث عن استئناس بعض
الحيوانات او كذا اين تم هذا كله تكشفه
علوم الاثار اشياء كثيره تكشفها علوم
الاثار الحديث تركز في الفتره الاخيره عن
العلا وحضاره الانبار لكن هل في الجزيره
العربيه حضرات اخرى لم تاخذ حقها من هذا
الامر هذا الشق الشق الثاني ما هو واقع
الاثار وعلم ومجال الاثار الميداني يعني
وحمايه الاثار وواقع التنقيب عن الاثار عن
هذه النقاط وغيرها يسعدني ان تكون ضيفتنا
في هذه الامسيه الباحثه السعوديه في مجال
الاثار والسياحه الاستاذه حصه بنت مروان
السديري حياك الله استاذ حسين
نبي نبدا على السريع على مرتهم
الضوء تسلط في السنوات الاخيره وهذا امر
جيد على حضاره الانباط ودادان والاحيان في
الانباط هل نحن في السعوديه نملك حضارات
اخرى تاخذ حقها من الضوء اكيد لان المملكه
بشكل عام بكل مساحتها في استيطان على مدار
السنين من عصور ما قبل التاريخ يعني نحكي
من واحد فاصله خمسه مليون سنه في نجران
الى اليوم في استمراريه طرق الطرق الحج في
الفترات الاسلاميه طرق التجاره كانت
الحروب كلها اللي صارت مع الاشوريين ومع
البابليين كانت بسبب وحتى مع الانباط
والرمان سيطرتهم عليها بسبب طرق التجاره
فهذا سبب اساسي كان موجود
وغير هذا كمان عندنا استيطان بشكل مستمر
الطبيعه المناخيه كانت تختلف من الاف
السنين حتى على مستوى الربع الخالي كانت
تختلف في الطبيعه المناخيه ما كان بهذه
الصحراء اللي نعرفها اليوم
طبعا الطبيعه المناخيه تتكلمين عن العصور
المطيره يعني انه كان في انهار كان فيه
تجمعات مياه بالتالي توفر قدره على
الاستيطان حوالينها يعني يعني عندك مثلا
من واحد مليون سنه كان في ثلاث اكبر انهار
تشق الجزيره العربيه من ضمنها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وتصب الخليج العربي هذه
الانهار حوالينا في استيطان حتى كانت
قريبه من نجد وفي عندك لما تشوف الصور
مثلا الرياض كيف كانت او منطقه نجد بشكل
عام كلها منطقه استوائيه فالواحد لما
يشوفها ممكن ما تصدق ان هذا الشيء كان من
مليون سنه فهذا شيء دائما ناخذ بعين
الاعتبار بالتنقيب عن المواقع نشوف كيف
كانت الطبيعه المناخيه قبل وهنا نستعين
انما نرجعها مثلا الى حوالي مليون سنه
للخلف عشان نتخيل كيف كان نشاط البشره
هناك البشر والحيوانات طبعا والحركه يعني
لو واحد بيسوي فيلم زي ابع ثلاثيه زي
افاتار ممكن يتخيل بدون مبالغه يا بت بس
بدون
الذرقان الاسطوريه يعني تخيلوا هذا وادي
حنيفه كان مليء بالمياه وغيره يعني من
المجاري المياه
طيب على هذا الذكر على ذكر وادي حنيفه
مثلا وقبل شوي ذكرنا العلا هل في اعمال
تنقيبيه
احترافيه جرت في هذا الحوض المسمى بوادي
حنيفه
بوابه قاعده تعمل وعندها قسم اثار حاليا
قاعدين يعملون اعمال تنقيب بكل هذيك
المنطقه بشكل عام بس الى الان لان بدات
على حسب علمي من سنتين مع تاسيس بوابه
الدرعيه فالى الان لسه ما اعلنوا عن
الدراسات اللي طلعت ويعني في هذيك المنطقه
بس في اعمال تنقيب قاعده تصير حاليا في
هذيك المنطقه بس انه سنتين اعتقد يعني وقت
جدا متاخر يعني ما في قبل ان تعرفي العلا
كان فيها اعمال من من ازمنه قديمه يعني
بعثات فرنسيه صح بس بناخذ كمان بعين
الاعتبار ان هذيك المنطقه اول كان كلها
سكان فعمله هم لما نسرب منطقه الدرعيه
بشكل عام صار في سلطه اكثر لانه في ناس
مثلا طلعوا من مناطقم او غيرها لان في
اسباب مثلا من عندك مواقع اثريه في كمال
للاسف بعضها تدمرت لانه مع استيطان السكان
وتوسع المدينه وغيرها لكن على الاقل يعني
الحمد لله نقول انه في استمراريه
يعني الان قاعدين يعني يسعفونها وينقذونها
لان هذا شيء جيد
وممتاز لانه فعلا انت مثل ما تفضلت اذا
نتخيل نشاط بشري نتخيلوا كما كان والظروف
المناخيه مختلفه يعني ماذا عن الحضارات
الاخرى طيب في
مثلا جنوب المملكه العربيه السعوديه شرق
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
هل كان في حضارات توازي او بقيمه مثلا
حضاره الانباط او في انا اشوف شخصيا حضاره
ما اخذت حقها من التاريخ عندك مملكه قدار
مملكه قدار
لمن كانت دائما بحروب مع الاشورين
والبابليين بعد انتصار الملك سلمان نصر
الثالث على مملكه قدار لما وثق الانتصار
كتب الملك جندب وملك العرب وهذا اقدم واول
ذكر لكلمه عرب فملكه قدار شعبها كانوا
طبيعه حياتهم الى الى حياتنا اليوميه للان
يعني البدو كانت قبائل لها الشيخ يحكمها
بعدين تطورت اصبحت مملكه والحكم وراثي في
عندك ملكات عربيات مثل ملكه زبيبه الملكه
شمسي كلهم ادارهم
مملكه قدار اللي عاصمتها الان دومه الجندل
كان اسمها دوماتو
اللي هي فيها قلعه مارد وهي تابعه لمملكه
قدار بس صار في استيطان للحضارات كثيره
مثل الفتره الاسلاميه والانباط وغيرها
فكانت الحروب مع الاشوريين كانت بسبب طرق
التجاره لانها تشق الى سوريا وتم العثور
مثلا في مصر على اواني تابعه
الملك مملكه قدار لكن وين الاواني مثلا
ممكن اسالك او المخلفات الاثريه اللي في
دومه الجندل هي عاصمتهم يعني ما نعرف مثلا
دائما يقول لك المنتصر يكتب التاريخ فكل
اللي نعرفه عن مملكه قيذار بناء على
النقوش الاشوريه اللي ذكرت مملكه قدار لكن
بالضبط وهذه الاشياء اللي يذكرها المنتزه
طبعا لا شك ان الاشوريين يعني حضاره كانت
الاقوى يعني في وقتها وكل شيء لكن وين
ممكن نقول مملكه قدار شعبها يحكي عن نفسه
فهذا اكيد انه موجود لكن هل تمت من قبل هل
في هل في اعمال تنقيبيه تمت في منطقه دومه
الجندل تمت لكن انا اللي قراتها كانت عن
العصور الكلاسيكيه لانها تعرف الرومان
احتلوا الانباط في نهايه حكمهم فعندك في
اثار
للرومان عندك نقوش على الصخور وغيرها وفي
اثار نبطيه واسلاميه لكن اثار المملكه
قدار حسب علمي اكون غلطانه ما اعرف اذا
عملوا حفريات اثريه بخصوصها لكن حتى عندك
بس كتاب واحد اللي انا قدرت احصل عليه
وتشكر عليه الدكتوره هند التركي كتبتها عن
مملكه قدار حتى هي تنوه بالكتابه تقول انه
اغلب اللي نعرفه عنهم من الاشورين
والبابليين لكن وين
اثار مملكه قدار وين مساكنهم وين يعني حتى
لما تشوفوا مثلا
بالرسومات الاشوريه يرسمونهم على الجمال
كانوا دائما حياه بداوا اللي هي الا اليوم
يعني الى اليوميه
وذكرتيلي ايضا عن حديث عن حضاره المقر
وين تقع هذه الحضاره انا بس بنوه على نقطه
انه لما حكينا في البدايه انك سالتني اذا
في حضارات في المملكه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الى الان في اكتشاف موقعين غيرت
مجرى تاريخ واكتشافات العصر الحجري الحديث
من ضمنها موقعين الموقع الاول اللي هو زي
ما ذكرت حضاره المقر قبل حضاره المقر
واكتشافها كان اقدم استئناس للخيول ينسب
لكازاخستان اللي هو 5000 قبل الميلاد بعد
اكتشاف حضاره المقر من 9000 في العشره
الاف سنه قبل الميلاد طلع هناك اقدم
استئناس للخيول فمن ضمنها كانوا حتى كانت
الطبيعه لما درسوا المنطقه وشافوا السكان
وطبيعتها
عثروا على تمثيل الكلاب السلوقي للصيد
الصقور زي حياتنا اللي قلقانه يعني احنا
نمارسها مثلا استئناس التماثيل للخيول من
مصنوعه من الحجر في وادي الدواسر يعني هذه
بفعل التنقيب انتجت لنا نتيجه غيرت
السرديه عن موضوع مثلا استئناس الخيول كان
المعتاده انه قال انها استانست في
كازاخستان قبل 5000 سنه طلع في فرق اربعه
الاف سنه ومش في كازاخستان في وادي
الدواسر في علم الاثر لما تكتشف حضاره
الاولى من نوعه تسميها على الموقع عشان
كذا سميت حضاره المقر وفي كمان موقع مهم
لنفس الفتره الحجريه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اللي هو اكتشاف
نقش الجمل اللي على الجبل عنده نقش الجمل
لانه واضح يستحق حديث خاص السميح عذرا فقط
نذهب الى استراحه قصيره فلا تذهبوا بعيدا
انتظروا حديث نقش الجبل
[موسيقى]
هلا بكم بعد الفاصل الماضي كان حديثنا وما
زال في برنامج الندوه هو عن الحضارات
القديمه في الجزيره العربيه لماذا نصلط
الضوء عليها من حين لاخر ما هي اهميتها
اقتصاديه
سياسيه وحتى علميا طبعا الحديث كان دائم
ومازال يتداول في السعوديه في الفتره
الاخيره عن حضاره الانباط والعلب وبعض
الحضارات الاخرى التي لم تاخذ نصيبها بنفس
الكثابه ولا حتى بنفس الاعمال الحفريه
فماذا عن الحضارات الاخرى في ارجاء اخرى
من المنطقه منطقه الجزيره العربيه التي
تحتل السعوديه معظم هذه المساحه ما هو
واقع علم الاثار ومواقع الحثريات في علم
الاثار ضيفتنا وشركتنا في هذه الندوه
الباحثه السعوديه المتميزه في علم الاثار
والسياحه الاستاذ حصه بنت مروان سديري
وكانت تحدثنا قبل الفاصل عن حضارتين لم
تاخذها قد
[موسيقى]
وزاره الثقافه وكمان من اهميه الاكتشاف
عمل ضجه في عالم الاثار بشكل عام الدولي
فليميز الموقع ان هذا اقدم اكتشاف
النحت الشكل الجمل الطبيعي
فنحيه الجمل كامل على جبل
وهملين كما عثر على الادوات اللي ناقشوا
فيها الجمل في نفس الموقع ليش هذا مميزا
نحن كاثري ما نشوف بس هذا نقش هذا مهم لا
معناته كان في جماعه فنانين يدربون النحت
كان المجتمع متطور انه في عنده جماعه
مختصه انها تعمل هذه الفنون وادوات جدا
بسيطه فهذا وعمر النحت من 5000 ل 400
الخمسه الاف وسبع مئه سنه قبل الميلاد هذا
من اهم الاكتشافات على مستوى دولي في
العصر الحجري الحديث اللي هو عندنا موقعين
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه واقول هذا
نقطه في بحر من الكنوز اللي موجوده عندنا
نقطه في بحر نقطه في بحر طيب هذا يمكن
يقودني للسؤال الان كم يعني لو بدنا نحط
نسبه مئويه
المكشوف عنه
سواء للعلماء او
من العامه مش اقول العامه للعموم عشان ما
يقول العامه يعني الجهل يعني للاعلام وكذا
لو بنحط نسبه مئويه من مجمل اثار المملكه
كم مئويا كم مكشوف منها
كان عشره بالميه او اقل اقل من عشره اقل
من عشره والسبب ليش يعني ليش ليش ما يكون
فيه نشاط اكبر في هذا المجال هو علم
الامريكي قله المتخصصين في هذا المجال
كمان ينحسب لنا صح احنا بدينا متاخر لكن
الحمد لله ما نهبت اثارنا لان تعرف اول مع
الرحاله لما يجون ومع التنقيب كثير من
الاثار انه هيبات فالحمد لله على الاقل ان
حتى لو متاخرين بس الحمد لله ما نهبت
اثارنا ما زالت موجوده عندنا
فمثلا لما نجي نشوف مساحه المملكه صح
للامانه نحتاج عدد اكبر من البعثات
الاثريه الدوليه اللي موجوده وفي من اهل
المهمه زي مثلا معهد ماكس بلانك الالماني
عمل كذا دراسه كذا بعثه اثريه والمميزه
كلها موجوده في موقعهم كل الدراسات اللي
عملوها بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه منها
اقدم من الجهه المانيه ايوه وفي عندك كمان
فرنسيه وايط مثلا تعاقدنا مع جامعه نابولي
لهيئه التراث لتنقيب الاثار الغارقه وهذا
كمان شيء مهم عندنا فالحمد لله في البحر
فهذا كمان جزء مهم لانه عندك مثلا
الموانئ القديمه وغيرها موجوده كلها هذه
تحت البحر كيف قد صار يعني في البحر
الاحمر او في الخليج العربي اعمال تنقيبيه
لا حسب علمي ما صار لنا الان تم التعاقد
السنه اللي فاتت مع جامعه نابولي لان عندك
موانع قديمه لنا الانباط كمان وصلوا
لايطاليا لهم معابد فهذا اللي بس نعرفه عن
الامراض يمكن في عصور قديمه كانت تعرف قبل
كم مليون سنه نقول الطبيعه كانت تختلف
فايش راح نلقى تحت البحر هذا كمان انظمه
من الاشياء بالمستقبل ان شاء الله راح
تغير كمان مجرى التاريخ زي مثلا السنه
اللي فاتت غيرنا مجرى التاريخ في اكتشاف
واحد وهذا الجميل بعلم الاثار ان انت ما
عندك كتاب معين ترجع له دائما حسب اخر
اكتشاف يتغير
ويعني تقولي الموانع النبطيه القديمه
معناته حتى حضارات الانباط لم تصل القصه
الى نهايتها يعني ما زال ما زلنا في اول
الكتاب مع الانباط اللي هم اكثر حضاره
اخذت حقها من الشغل والتنقيب ما بالك
باللي لسه يعني المملكه جدا غنيه في
الاثار والحضارات اللي موجوده يعني عندك
فقط في منطقه واحده لنعرف عنها تقريبا سبع
حضارات اذا مو اكثر اللي الان نعرف عنا
ففي علم الاثار دائما في كثير تصير انها
مع التنقيبات يعثرون على حضارات ما قد
سمعوا عنها من قبل ذات عندك العصور
الحجريه ما كان في كتابك لا رسومات فممكن
نكتشف موقع اقدم
الاستيطاني الانسان هجره ممكن نلقى عظام
اقدم لان المواقع اللي من مليون سنه من
مليون سنه ما لقينا عظام الهيكل العظمي او
شيء للانسان فقط مستوطنات او ادوات فعندك
كمان الربع الخالي الربع الخلفي كثير من
الاثار عندك بحيرات كانت
الاستيطان جنبها
متعه في التنقيب عن الاثار انا تجربتك
الشخصيه سبق قمت باعمال تنقيب
وين سويتوها وايش المتعه فيها وهل هي
عمليه صعبه هي صراحه اذا انت شخص توه هذا
الشيء عمليه انا دائما اقول كاني اسافر
عبر الزمن لانه انت تحفر يعني اتذكر مره
موقف كنا نحفر خاصه بخلص حفر عشان وارجع
لسه كان عندي محاضرات بالجامعه فالدكتور
قال اني اطلع برا المربع فجاه جاني دكتور
خلاص ابغى اخلص
فطلعنا فقال ناظر المربع حقك ايش تشوفين
فناظرت المربع وفعلا لقيت هنا فجاه هذا
الجهه الجهه في كانت سوداء وجيها في عندها
زي مطحنه وفي جهه عندها فتحه حقت الخيمه
قال طب الحين ايش تشوفين قلت هذا كان اكيد
المطبخ وهنا كانوا الخيمه يعني وين
يركبونها وهنا كانوا وين يطحنون قال
معناته بندخل نشوف ايش كانوا ياكلون فلازم
تطلع بره فبعدين استوعبت انه تصير تستوعب
انه انا اشرح القى الحين فيع تصور الحياه
الانسان البساطه يعني احيانا تلقى حتى
الفخاره زي ما هي مو مكسوره ولا شيء
فالجميل بعلم الاثار انك تدخل بدون اي
تفكير يعني ما تدخل على تفكيرك انك بالفين
2023 لا تدخل عندك ما تعرف اي زمن راح
تصادف فتعيش التجربه ايش ممكن تلقى ايش
الاشياء اللي راح تتوقع تلقاها واشياء
تفاجئك لان دائما اروح ما نعرف اسال
الدكتور ايش ممكن نلقى اليوم يقول ما
تعرفون هذا الجميل انك ممكن تقعد اسبوع ما
تلقى شيء يعني اول فتره قاعد ما لقينا شيء
بدي اطلع لنا معبد وين هذا تل السخنه
بالاردن
وحفرنا في جرش كمان كان في تقنيه تجي
فيزيكس في الاجهزه التي ترسل اشارات وتعرف
اذا في تحتك فتقريبا بالاردن ترى في كل
الاردن حفرت يعني
انه احنا نروح للمكان الفلاني هل هي مثلا
انه في معلومات مكتوبه في المصادر الكتب
ان هذه موقع اثار ولا مثلا واحد يلقى شيء
بالصدفه يعني ايش المعيار طبعا تختلف حسب
العصر اللي تبحث عنه فمثلا لو انا ابحث عن
عصر مثلا بعد 3000 سنه قبل الميلاد اللي
فيه كتابه في ممكن زي ما ذكرت تكون مصادر
تاريخيه احيانا تلقى مباني وفي اهم شيء
احنا لازم
دائما نروح له السكان المحليين لان ارضى
يعرفها
ايه فعلى طول احيانا قبل ما نبدا مثلا
نسوي المسح الاثري نلجا للسكان المحليين
لانه بيختصر ثلاثه ايام فيقول لي على
الاقل ممكن من وين اعرف ابدا
فتعتمد حسب العصر اللي انت قاعد تبحث عنه
نعود الى السعوديه من
ما هي ملاحظاتك ولو بشكل موجز عن واقع
التنقيب والحفريات في السعوديه طبعا لو
نقارنها مثلا من خمسه او سبعه سنين على
الاقل نقول الحين صار في شفافيه يعني صار
في تواصل صار فيه يعني صح ان الانباط الان
نسمع عنها كثير لكن قبل في كثير ناس ما
كانت تعرف عن الامراض فاهم شيء اللي صار
عندنا الحين التوعيه وهذا اهم شيء ان
الناس تعرف انه في اثار عدم منا الناس
تروح لاي موقع في عندك وحده والله انا
اهوى الاثار ابغى اجمع هذا لا
فصار عندك هنا في حفريات لكن العدد ما زال
قليل مقارنه بحجم المملكه بحجم الحضارات
اللي موجوده عندنا
يعني اذا يعني ما هي دعوته في هذا الخصوص
بحكم تخصصك فيها طبعا الميدانيه يعني انا
الى الان ما اشتغلت ميدانيا يعني عندك
التجربه ذي التعاون مع بعثات يعني الكل
عصر يعني مثلا انا قاعده ابغى افهم مثلا
لغز هجره الانسان من افريقيا للجزيره
العربيه ايش المواقع يعني نروح المواقع
هذا الانسان المتحضر الاول القديم لان هذه
كلها تفكر لك لغز عشان هي زي قاعده تجمع
انت عشان تفهم فنعرف هذه المواقع هل فيها
ياكل عظميه لهذه الفترات هل في حضاره
مختصه موجوده فقط عندنا بالمملكه
وكمان
ممكن نقول نشر الابحاث اكثر لانه في كثير
الابحاث العلميه اللي صارت في المملكه
سهول اني انا اقدر اوصل لها يعني تكون
بشكل عام وهذا تعتقدين انه مش بالشكل
المطلوب اليوم يعني هو موجود لكن مو
بالشكل المطلوب بالشكل المطلوب ايضا
سعاد ايضا سريع كيف تقيمين تعامل الناس
العاديين لواحد يلقى له شيء ولا يلقى له
هل ارتفع مستوى الثقافه ولا لك تجربه
بصراحه صراحه نشوف مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي كثير ناس يعني تروح مثلا
من موقع فتلقاها راجعه للبيت وتصور
الادوات يعني انت كده هدمت 50% من الماده
العلميه اللي هي انت وين لقيتها كيف شكلها
ايش كانت جنبها فهنا في ناس وفي ناس يحطون
في ناس تاخذ بعض الادوات مثلا يشوف قرش
مثلا عليه صدى يروح مثلا يسمع يقرا انه في
زيت زيتون لا في ناس متخصصه هي اللي تعمل
وهي اللي تقوم بترميم القطع يعني زي مره
مثلا كان في فريق ايطالي في قصير عمره
بالاردن جاي بس عشان يشيل طبقه الرماد من
الرسومات لان فقط تخيل فريق يعني هذا تخصص
الحاله ما راح يشيل من من الحجم انه يشيل
الاشياء العنيفه بس المشكله انه كذا انت
قاعد تتلاعب بالتاريخ يعني ممكن انت القرش
اللي اخذته هو القرش الوحيد اللي موجود في
كل المنطقه يدلني ان في حضاره هذه مرت من
المنطقه فعدم الاستهتار ان اي احد يروح
ياخذها وهذي ملك للدوله ما حد يملكها انا
بسال سؤال ختامي بس
اذكر في بعض الدول الاخرى عربيه وغير
عربيه في جهه خاصه هي التي تتولى حمايه
الاثار
مش هيئه علميه او لا لا جهه يعني زي بعضهم
يسميها شرطه الاثار او ما ادري هل موجود
هذا عندنا ولا حسب علمي ما صراحه ما اعرف
اذا موجود او لا عندي لانه تعرف هذا
المجال كله لسه عندنا جديد قاعد يعني
وجوده طبعا لان زي ما قلت لك الحين يعني
في ناس تروح الى اليوم وتروح تاخذ اي قطعه
وتروح لبيتها وتصورها
بالضبط والتجاره انت كذا قاعد تلعب
بالتاريخ يعني
فعندك مثلا الناس اللي تروح ممكن حتى من
الكوارث الطبيعيه زي السيور الامطار حوامل
عوامل الحث والتاني هذه كلها تلعب دور
فمثلا اذا موقع راح مثلا قلت احد من
جدرانه ينهد سرعه معالجه معالجه الموقع
على الاقل اعمال بسيطه عشان نحافظ عليه
المواقع اللي تكون عندك مثلا حتى على
النقوش القديمه تلقى ناس لسه قاعده تشخمط
فوقها فهذه كلها تحتاج حمايه مراقبه ممكن
التكنولوجيا كاميرات حساسات او غيرها
يعني التجربه على فكره عملت في موضوع
البيئه البيئه او حمايه واثمرت ثمار جيدا
حمايه الاشجار
تنفذ هذه القوانين وتسهر على تنفيذه لكن
حتى لا يدركنا السهر والوقت نفذ انا اشكرك
استاذه حصه بنت مروان سديري واحيي شغفك
هذا بعلم الاثار وعملك النظري والميداني
هذه اعتقد المزيج المطلوب في الانسان فعلا
الذي يريد ان ينتج شيء متميز واحسبك كذلك
واشكركم مشاهدينا الكرام على بقائكم معنا
ومستمعينا ايضا على بقائكم معنا في هذا في
هذه الجوله والتحليق
المنخفض لنرى عن قرب بعض ملامح الغابرين
والسالفين من اجدادنا العظام في الجزيره
العربيه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]